Shanks
mihawk Roger all three characters are
some of the most powerful in all of One
Piece and they all have one really
interesting thing in common no devil
fruits now of course they have
unbelievable hockey and sword skills but
that's not the point of this video
because I want to take these already
insanely overpowered characters and make
them absolutely Untouchable by finding
the absolutely perfect devil fruit for
all the strongest non-evil fruit users
in all of One Piece and we're going to
kick this off with possibly the
strongest character ever and yes I'm of
course talking about the one and only
former pirate king Goldie rer who mostly
overwhelmed his enemies with his god
tier level hockey Supreme swordsmanship
and possibly the strongest and greatest
crew to ever sail the Seas and yet one
thing that Roger never had as far as as
we know at least is an absolutely broken
devil fruit ability and I'll be honest
when thinking about this perfect devil
fruit for Roger the very first fruit
that came to mind was his son's devil
fruit the flame flame fruit and that's
because Asus loia power is just so op
because it allows you to literally shoot
out Flames create giant waves of fire
and especially for a swordsman like
Roger you can code your entire sword in
Flames as well to cut down enem with
devastatingly powerful fiery slashes
however then when thinking about it a
little bit more there is one devil fruit
that would meet Rogers need even better
than the flame fruit and that is of
course the legendary na devil fruit that
was eaten by our main character Luffy
and funnily enough for the longest time
before we ever got the reveal about the
true nature of the rubber fruit many
fans thought that Roger might have
actually eaten this devil fruit however
since we now know that Awakening this
fruit basically allows you to become the
legendary figure Joy boy well then we
just have to give this one to Roger and
in case you're wondering that's of
course because when Roger and his crew
finally reached the last Island love
tale for some unknown reason they were
too early there to use whatever they
found now that could simply have been a
time thing like they didn't show up at
the right moment or it might have just
been because they needed Joy boy to
awaken in order to actually use the
secret treasure left behind by the
ancient Kingdom in fact we have some
hint about this when Shanks decided to
finally go after the one piece himself
after he learned that Luffy had awakened
his fruit so giving Roger the NAA devil
fruit might be the only one to really
make sense because it means that he
could have actually used whatever he
found on love tale if he was Joy boy
himself Plus on top of that we all know
that Roger personality is insanely
similar to Luffy so I'm very sure that
he would have eventually awakened this
fruit as well and made full use of its
broken abilities but now that Roger has
his devil fruit we of course also need
one for his rightand man here reallyy
and the so-called dark King fights in
basically the exact same way as his
captain but I have a very very different
devil fruit in mind for Luffy's mentor
and that's because rley here has
basically almost unmatched speed and
Power in his prime but we could take
these already busted stats and turn them
all the way up to maximum by giving him
the light devil fruit which would allow
him to move at light speed swing his
sword with even more devastating power
and of course shoot off light bullets to
take out enemies from a distance and
fittingly enough reallyy has been linked
to this particular fruit ever since he
actually clashed with Admiral kizaru
during the Saba ODI archipelago Arc and
so even though that this fruit would be
perfect for the dark King I'm actually
thinking that another fruit might be
even better for Ry during his prime year
that's because we know that he already
was such a top tier fighter but one
thing that he couldn't ever do is help
his captain stay alive once Roger got
his deadly disease and so what if we
gave Ry the Phoenix fruit because of its
special healing abilities and in case
you forgot this fruit is a mythical Zone
fruit that turns the user into this
Majestic blue phoenix that can fly
around like a regular bird but the
unbelievable special ability of this
fruit is to use the magical blue flames
here to heal yourself and most
importantly other people as well and so
what if by having this ability really
could not only fight a lot stronger but
have actually cured his captain or if
not that then maybe at least extend his
lifespan by giving him a regular supply
of healing Flames plus let's be real I
just think that the idea of a flying
swordsman is just incredibly awesome as
we saw with king so I'm giving this
fruit to Ry but as hard as it is to
believe Roger and reallyy are not even
the strongest members of their own crew
in this video and if you don't know what
I'm talking about that's because we're
going to give the perfect devil fruit to
Shanks as well in just a few minutes but
before we get to the absolute Insanity
that I have in mind for the red-haired
Emperor we first need to talk about the
man who used to hunt down the Roger
Pirates himself monkey the GARP and
unlike Roger and rayley Luffy's
grandfather is just a straightup brawler
who fights with his bare knuckle fists
however if you know anything about doy's
old man then you'll know that these
fists are basically nuclear weapons as
he can wipe out entire cities with a
single punch which means that we of
course have to ask ourselves the hard
question what even would be the perfect
devil fruit to give to a man as already
powerful as this and actually the first
thing I thought was giving him the
Buddha fruit which was eaten by his old
friend and former Fleet Admiral sangoku
and I think it would make a lot of sense
that's because eating this fruit allows
GARP to transform into an enormous
Golden Buddha with giant fists and the
ability to send out huge shock waves but
then after giving it a little bit more
thought I'm actually a little bit
concerned that this fruit particularly
would slow Garb down plus that giant
body might make GARP extra hungry so our
next Contender here is the biscuit fruit
which would allow him to make an endless
supply of delicious biscuits because as
we know one of garp's favorite foods in
the world is rice crackers which I think
he'd be able to make with this devil
fruit as well and while this would
certainly satisfy his hunger cravings
and be a kind of quirky fruit to give
gar I still think it's not quite the
most impressive fruit for him so let's
give him the class of Luffy treatment
where we take his punches and you know
just make them bigger and of course we
can do exactly that with the deomi which
as we see right here allows its user to
freely change their size to make them
into enormous humans that are literally
the size of mountains and while we
earlier mentioned that guard being
bigger was maybe a bad thing since it
would make him slower I like to think
that he could keep his normal form for
Speed and then when he wants to then
change his size right before punching
someone to create a truly massive impact
which I mean if his regular power allows
him to destroy entire cities then with
this power let's be real he would
probably be able to destroy entire
islands and if we're thinking about it
though I think garp's Apprentice Kobe
might someday even surpass the Legendary
Marine here and to do that he might just
need the perfect devil fruit himself and
lucky for the pink hered Marine well
we're here to uh help with just that and
let me warn you these options are just
going to absolutely blow your mind let's
kick it off by considering the ice devil
fruit you know casually which in case
you forgot was eaten by the former
Marine Admiral aliji and ever since aiji
left the Marines there has always been a
chance that he could die which means
that Kobe could in fact theoretically
eat this devil fruit sometime in the
future but like most loas it's just
absurdly powerful with the ability to
freeze anything shoot out icy blasts and
even create ice weapons to use against
opponents but let's be real what makes
this fruit truly perfect for Kobe here
is that we recently learned that aliji
here was also a beloved student of GARP
so there is some history to go with this
fruit and Kobe but then on the other
hand if we're being honest Kobe is much
more of a Clos distant fist fighter just
like his mentor so let's think of a
fruit that will go with his regular
fighting style and this is going to blow
your mind because with Kobe's expert
levels of hockey and destructive punches
well he is most comfortable fighting at
close range however against many devil
fruit users who prefer to fight from
further away Kobe might be at a
disadvantage in many occasions so let's
fix exactly that weakness and let's give
him the only devil fruit that can make
sure you have close-range combat against
other devil fruit users which
coincidentally is the darkness loia
fruit originally eaten by Blackbeard
which I know does sound absolutely
insane but let me explain what I think
here so we all know that Blackbeard's
Powers allow him to shoot out darkness
and trap people inside his black holes
but one of the other abilities that I
think people tend to forget sometimes is
that it allows him to suck in Devil
frood users so that he can touch them
and such erase the devil fruit abilities
and in fact once he has hold of them he
can then beat them down so if we gave
this power to Kobe he would always be
able to fight any devil fruit user up at
close range and deal massive blows like
this yeah this power alone would make
Kobe one of the most feared fighters in
the entire world however funnily enough
you might already describe this next
character exactly in that way because
dracul mihawk is the world's strongest
swordsman periods and while we've
actually never seen him fight all out
which is kind of nuts that far into the
story well we can just imagine that he
has absolute top tier hockey to match
his absolutely insane sword skills since
he was set to fight on par with Shanks
back in their early days which does mean
that he technically doesn't really need
a devil fruit but just like Kobe
mihawk's fighting style could also be
enhanced by the darkness fruit abilities
for example if mihawk ate the darkness
fruit he could use his Darkness pocket
Dimension to store different types of
swords and weapons and pull them out
whenever he needs them or I guess he
could use it the same way that we
discussed with Kobe and suck people in
but since mihawk can already send quite
insane flying slashes he doesn't really
need the ability to get people close to
him as Kobe does and so if we think in a
different direction what he actually
does need is this because you know come
on who wouldn't love to see a winged
version of this dark swordsman flying
Ling around and chasing down his enemies
and I mean if we're talking about a
devil fruit with wings for me Hawk then
probably the best one would be the
Falcon fruit which was once eaten by
this Alabaster Royal Guard here and yeah
I know it's not exactly the same as his
name I actually did the extra research
to see if there was a hawk fruit to fit
mihawk's name but the Falcon fruit is
the best that we could find in the
actual story and speaking of Swordsmen
this next one is kind of different from
every other Swordsmen out there because
Odin kazuki's two swword style was
nearly strong enough to already take
down the emperor kaido and while
admittedly his hockey levels are
probably a tier below those of Roger or
the other top tiers on this list Odin is
still an extremely overpowered fighter
who would possibly even reach the top
with the help of the perfect devil fruit
but let's be real picking the perfect
devil fruit for someone like Odin is
actually really difficult now obviously
any loia fruit would be a real boost to
anyone's overall defense and power but
based on his personality I think a truly
hilariously well-fitting option would
once again be the Buddha fruit I mean
come on Odin just does seem like the guy
who would love to walk around naked as a
giant Golden Buddha but the option that
best balances his powers defense and
Odin sword style would actually be the
heat fruit this one was originally eaten
by one of big mom's children and I do
know that it sounds like a kind of sick
joke because Odin was literally boiled
to death but with the powers of the heat
fruit well Odin might be resistant to
such high degree temperatures meaning
that his fruit would give him a great
chance to survive the boiling and on top
of that he could also send out massive
heat waves set people on fire or even
add flaming heat to his impressive two
sword style of fighting just like this
guy right here and now with Odin's new
blazing swords out of the way we can
finally talk about the one and only
straw hat on this list and while I've
already done a fulllength video on Zoro
and sanji's perfect devil fruits that
you can watch after this I also think
that the straw hats Helmsman jimbe is
another perfect candidate for a devil
fruit boost because let's be real he's
already an insanely powerful fighter
with his Mastery of Fishman karate and
his ability to manipulate water somewhat
so obviously something water or ice
related would be probably perfect for
him for example something like the ice
devil fruit would fit insanely well with
his PO is because he could move water
around and then freeze it at the perfect
time or another water related ability is
the swim fruit which we now know that
Jim Bas clone actually already has so of
course this would also be an insanely
good option for someone as good a
swimmer as jimbe however despite these
two great options I'm actually going to
go in the complete opposite direction
here because I do think that jimbe would
be the perfect character to use the
firef fruit huh what the let me let me
let me explain here because with his
natural water manipulation Techniques
plus the power of the flame fruit jimbe
could be a fire and water wielding
Master the likes of which the world of
One Piece has literally never seen
before but if you think that Jim's
fighting style is unique here just wait
until we discuss the perfect devil fruit
for this next character because now we
have lucky Ru who is one of shang's
all-time top officers we honestly
haven't seen fighting all that much well
he obviously did use a gun back in
chapter 1 and in film red we actually
saw him bouncing around as this giant
spinning ball so to find his perfect
devil fruit it's going to be quite
tricky here although we do know that
he's always eating basically so maybe
just giving him the cook cook fruit is
the best choice here I mean that would
let him turn anything and everything
into food and eat it so sounds pretty
good to me but another really good
option probably is to enhance his
bowling ball fighting style and just
give him the Tonton fruit formerly eaten
by this guy here which basically allows
the user to dramatically increase their
body weight at will and I'm talking up
to 10 million kilog which I mean roughly
equals to about 10,000 cars in other
words imagine lucky R smashing into you
with that kind of weight as a spinning
ball I mean let's be real you'd probably
just turn into dust or something however
this is shank's crew that we're talking
about and I do really feel like we need
something extra special here even for
liru so why not give him the light loia
devil fruit because I just literally
can't help myself from smiling at the
image of luyo Dashing around with his
weight at the speed of light and
honestly that kind of speed plus all the
other insane powers of the light fruit
with his raw strength could even let
Lucky defeat the next character on this
list maybe because while lucky Yu is
undoubtedly very powerful Shin's
right-hand man and second in command Ben
Beckman has an even more impressive
reputation for one he did frighten an
admiral pre- time Skip and is known to
be both an expert Marksman brawler and
most importantly he is one of the
smartest characters in the entire story
and honestly that fact alone probably
means that Ben Beckman could use nearly
any devil fruit exceptionally well in
just some examp examp here could be the
book fruit that could let him trap
people in an ultimate Dimension the
nine-tailed fruit which would let him
shape shift into other people which just
has all kinds of uses for an intelligent
person or even say l op op noi which is
just one of the alltime most complicated
fruits to learn and get good at but also
has one of the highest Potentials in the
entire story periods which honestly all
of these would probably be amazing fits
for Shanks as rightand man but there is
one other fruit out there that truly
fits Ben Beckman the best and ladies and
gentlemen let me direct you to the
magnet fruit yeah I mean this fruit
would be insane in Ben backman's hands
clearly it is a tough fruit to use
because it does require such precise
control and knowledge of machines and
metal but in Ben beckman's hands he
could literally create anything out of
metal rail guns an endless variety of of
weapons a battleship or if we're going
really crazy here maybe even a giant
mech suit for himself in other words
truly this fruit and Beckman would be a
match made in heaven especially after
Beckman basically already insulted its
current user but let me tell you that
nothing and I mean nothing compares to
the pure Majesty of what's going to come
next because now we're finally going to
talk about the character that I am
probably you have been waiting for from
the start and that is the captain of the
redhead Pirates himself Shanks and
honestly I don't even want to go mess
around with any of the other not as good
options here because there is only one
fruit that is the absolute perfect one
for Shanks in my mind and that is this
yeah just imagine how cool it would be
to have this enormous red hockey spewing
dragon flying over a battlefield and I
mean after fight in kaido for most of
wano we all pretty much know the
insanely awesome powers that this Dragon
form truly has with all its elemental
powers like lightning blast breath wind
slashes and much much more but eating
this fruit would also enhance shank's
strength speed durability and also
recovery time and honestly on top of
that can you just imagine the insanity
of Shanks in his Dragon hybrid form
wielding a sword I mean he'd be super
buffed up with his body covered in
impenetrable red scales and his massive
sword like man this would be a truly
terrifying side for any opponent and
just imagine all of this combined with
shank's truly unmatched and godly levels
of hockey would surely be enough to take
down anyone and I mean anyone in the
entire one piece world except Luffy of
course and now I'm just really wondering
who would actually win in a straight up
fight of dragon forms drag Shanks or
Dragon Luffy I mean either way it would
be a truly Earth shattering contest and
if you want to see how Luffy would use
the dragon fruit himself plus any of the
other insane Yono devil fruits as well
you can watch that video right here shks
so much for watching please don't forget
to like share subscribe that really
helps out the channel and I will
hopefully see you in the next one